on arrive élite est montréal québec
reprend de plus belle tout d'abord je
vais vous laisser en juger avec
l'extrait qui suit le lors de cette
conférence de presse ce matin on a
questionné régis labeaume à savoir s'il
avait eu une conversation avec le
nouveau maire de montréal que régis
labeaume nous a dit pour la petite
histoire c'est que ça faisait huit fois
qu'ils sont attachés que son équipe
tentait de rejoindre denis coderre sans
succès alors voici comment il a réagi m
ne pas ouvrir chaque année ça commence
de bonne à ben c'est bien curieux
témoins matin le premier s'appelle les
chefs de partis si mal à bordeaux